ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องอัดดี
สวัสดีค่ะนะเรียนเพียรเด้
วันนี้กลับมาเจออ่าขั้วตี้กับครูพี่เอ๋
อีกแล้วค่ะป้อมเกรียนสโมทัยนะครับ
ระดับอะไรนะบีกินเนอร์สี่ห้าสี B4 ครับ 5
วันนี้ไม่เจอครู Arty ครูเอ๋ครู Arty ไม่
เจอกันนานนาน
น่ากลัวแต่คิดว่าไม่เจอกันประมาณ 2 เดือน
สองเดือนไหม
[เพลง]
1 เดือนแสดงว่าครู Arty เนี่ยคิดอยากจะ
คุยกับครูเอก
ถึงคิดว่านานแล้วไงน่าจะประมาณ 1 เดือน
ค่ะ 1 เดือนได้ 1 เดือนนะครับวันนี้ครับ
วันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันนี้เนี่ยวันที่
อ่า
วันวันๆวันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันจันทร์หน้า
ใช่ครับวันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่คะครู Arty
วันจันทร์วันนี้วันที่ 9 ครับ 5  One
Piece
ใช่ครับเดือนอะไรคะ 5 เดือนนี้เดือนอ่า
พฤษภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมเรียนที่ 5 มะขาม 5
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะคศ
2010  22 ครับ
2022 ราคาปีพตเท่าไหร่คะผช
2565 ครับต้อง
565 นะครับได้ครับ
กู Arty แล้วตอนนี้เวลา
คะตอนนี้ใช่ไหมครับตอนนี้เวลาอ่า
08:10 นอ่ะ 8:30 น 8:00 นต้องเป็นที่ 8
ใช่ไหมคนไทยที่รัก 20:00 นแต่
8:00 น 8:30 นค่ะเป็นตอนกลางคืน 2 อัตรา
รายคือ
โอนนอนไหมคะ
ยังไม่ง่วงกับยังไม่ง่วงก็เพราะว่ากู
อาทิตย์เดี๋ยวคุยกับครูเอ๋เสร็จก็มีต่อ
อีกฮ่าๆๆใจกับอย่าเพิ่งง่วงครับนักเรียน
ก็อย่าเพิ่งง่วงมาฟัง
ตื่นก่อนนะครับก็ตื่นมาฟังอ่า
หวัดกูเอกก่อนอ่ะ
กวนตีคะอันนี้เนี่ยเราเล็กซีรีส์นี้ดี
กว่าไหมอัดซีรี่ย์นี้เลยแสดงว่ามีหลายมี
หลายเรื่องใช่ไหมมีหลายเรื่องค่ะซีรีส์
นี้ครู Arty กับครูเอ๋นะคะคุยกันเราจะ
เป็นซีรีส์จังหวัดและต่าง
ประเทศไทยในประเทศไทยมีหลายจังหวัดใช่ไหม
ครับหน้าให้มีทั้งหมดเนี่ยกี่จังหวัดนะคะ
a กี่จังหวัดนะครับมีกับมิ 6  7 โว่มี
มากกว่านั้นครับครัวคั่วแต่คิดว่าน่าจะมี
น่าจะมี 7
77 จังหวัดไหมใช่ค่ะมี 77 จังหวัดนะคะ
เล็กเราจะพานักเรียนไป 77 จังหวัดมั้ยอ๋อ
อาจจะพระเจ้าไม่
ใช่กับเขาจังหวัดที่เคยไปที่ควรดิเคยไป
ที่อาผู้เหี๊ยเคยไปหน้ารึหรือหรือครูเอ๋
คิดอยากจะไปอ๋อๆ
ผมขอโทษ 77 จังหวัดโลโก้องค์
[เพลง]
กรหนึ่งร้อยคลิปๆ 5 มีเยอะๆแล้วมีอะไรมาก
ๆนะคะได้ครับงั้นคลิปแรกเลยของปีนี้มั้ย
อ๋อปีนี้หรอของซีรี่ส์นี้ของซีรี่ส์นี้
r-con ซีรีส์นี้เนี่ยครู Arty คะเราจะไป
ไหนดีค่ะ 5 เดี๋ยวครัวติ๊ดพาไปใกล้ๆก่อน
ถ้าไปใกล้ๆๆใกล้อะไรไปกะศิษย์ที่อเมริกา
ไม่ราวใกล้เมียนว่า
มาเลเซียอ้าเอาใกล้ๆกรุงเทพฯครับ 5 ใกล้
นะไม่ใช่ไกลไปใกล้ๆหน้าไปที่เทพลมีสี
เขียวใช่ไหมคะอ่าใช่ครับลงสีเขียวเขียวๆ
พรุ่งนี้สีเขียวเขียวๆตรงนี้ครับ
จังหวัดอะไรนะ 5 จังหวัดอะไรอยู่ตรงสี
เขียวๆนี้ครับสีแดงณจังหวัดกรุงเทพฯนะคะ
ได้เป็นเมืองหลวงนะคะเมืองหลวงแต่ครู Arty
กำลังจะพาไปสีเขียวๆๆแค่ตรงนั้นไม่ใช่
ทั้งหมดนะคะ
ตรงนี้ห่าจังหวัดอะไรคะครู Arty จังหวัด
กาญจนบุรี
kanchanaburi
kanchanaburi เล็กคู่เอกคิดนะคะครูเอก
คิดว่านักเรียนเนี่ยนักเรียนที่ฟังเรา
เนี่ยอะรู้จักเนาะ
ใช่เคยได้ยินได้ยินจังหวัดกาญจนบุรีได้
ครับอ่า
เสือกาญจนบุรี
โอะยาว 5 คำ
กาญจนบุรี 5 คำพูดสั้นๆไหมค่ะอ้าถ้าพูด
สั้นๆคนไทยเรียกจังหวัดกาญจนบุรี
ปาร์ตี้ไปไหนกูอะที่บอกไปไปจังหวัด
กาญจนบุรี
ยาวใช่ไหมได้คนที่ก็จะบอกว่าคนที่ก็จะบอก
ว่า
หาขวดดิไปการครับไปการครับ
สั้นเลยนะ
วันนี้เราไม่พูดกาญจนบุรีแล้วเนอะเราพูด
ไปการโอเคไหมโอเควันนี้เราไปการการครับ
เราเป็นการกันค่ะค่ะนักเรียนไปไปการอะ
เดี๋ยวกูอะตี้พาไปการค่ะครับอ่ะไปการไปทำ
อะไรกันครับพิการวันนี้
ไปที่เอาใช่ไหมโอเคครูเอ๋เคยอยู่ในการ
น่าจะ 3 ครั้งขอครับ
นะคะน่ากลัวนี่ก็เคยไปน่าจะนะจ๊ะอ่าหลาย
ครั้งนะครับอาจจะ 5 ครั้งเว่ย 5 เขาเอกก็
อยากไปแล้วอะตี้แต่ว่าคู่เอกไปการเนี่ย
เอาไปรถไฟขอ
เหนื่อยไหม
แต่ตอนนั้นเด็กๆนะเด็กๆก็โอเคเออแสดงแล้ว
นะไปถั่วรถไฟราคารถไฟไปการโอเคว้าวเวลา
ครูเอ๋เด็กๆน่ะ 55 บาทอ๋อห้าสิบห้าบาทถูก
ถูกๆไม่แพงแต่ว่ารถไฟไหม้ดีแอร์แล้วร้อน
ร้อนสิครับถ้าไม่มีอะไรก็ร้อนนะหานี่ไม่
ต้องไปถ้าไป 05:00 นอ๋อไปรถที่รถไฟตีห้า
ใช่ไหมครับถ่าย
[เพลง]
545 แล้วก็กลับมาถึงกรุงเทพฯประมาณ 18:00
นกลับมาถึงกรุงเทพฯ 18:00 นประมาณนะ
ประมาณนะฮะ
1 วันนะคะหนึ่งวัน
อาจนะกรุงเทพกาญจนบุรี
ผู้ก่อน
กูเอาตีวาดรูปรถไฟให้ด้วยนะคะรถไปใช่ไหม
ครับ
รถไฟหน้าตาเป็น
แบบนี้นะครับแล้วก็มีมีควันอยู่ข้างบนแบบ
นี้ไหมอ้าวไปรถรถไฟไทยนะคะ
เหมือนรถไปไม่เอาเหมือนค่ะเหมือนกันเอา
เป็นรถไฟแล้วก็ขับรถรถไฟท้ายก็จะมีมี
โบกี้เนาะมีมิลหัว
แล้วก็มีโบกี้ 1 โบกี้ 2  +  20 สัตว์ๆ
อันนี้สิ่งศักสิทธิ์
ได้ครับติดกันแบบนี้ค่ายถ้า
ได้ครับ
ชั่วโมงว้าวรถไฟวิ่งช้าก็เลยราคาถูกใช่
ไหมครับราคา 55 บาทถูกมาก
ไปกลับ 55 บาทอ้าวแต่ขวดอิ๊กคิดว่าตอนนี้
ถ้าตอนนี้ไปซื้อน่าจะแพงอยู่แล้วถ้า
สามารถกว่า 55 วันนี้มันคู๋อายุ 10  10
10  10 ๆประมาณ 30 กว่าปีที่แล้วโค้ช
อ๊อดโอ้โหน้ำ
30 กว่าปีที่แล้วเนี่ย 55 บาทตอนก็ไม่
รู้อาจจะ 200  300  R นะคะอาจจะ 200 บาท
มา
ครู Arty คะ
แล้วนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะถามกูอีก
นั่งรถไปที่ไหนเหรอ
หัวลำโพงค่ะตอนนี้ปิดแล้วค่ะอ้าเขาย้ายมา
แล้วครับย้ายเข้ามาอีกนิดนึงที่บางซื่อๆ
ซื่อกับครูปาร์ตี้ค่ะแล้ววันนี้นะที่ไป
ล่ะไปรถไฟกลับไปรถตู้ไปไปยังไงหน้าวันนี้
ขับรถไปควรติ๊กขับรถไปเองใช่ครับง่ายขับ
รถยนต์ไปสวัสดีขับรถไปกรุงเทพฯกาญจนบุรี
ใช้เวลาเท่าไหร่คะใช้เวลาประมาณ 1
ชั่วโมง 30 นาที 1 ชั่วโมง 30 นาทีให้
ครับประมาณประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมงอีกสามสิบนาที
ความเร็วเท่าไหร่
ความเร็วควรตีขับรถไม่เร็วสวัสดีขับรถ
ประมาณอ่า 100
บาทถึง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
120 ไม่เลว
เปลี่ยนจะตกใจ
120 ไปเร็วไม่ได้เป็นหน่วยเป็นกิโลเมตร
ต่อชั่วโมงนะของคนไทยคนไทยเราเรียก
กิโลเมตรต่อชั่วโมงถ้าเป็นหนังต่างประเทศ
จะเรียกต่อมายถ้าใหม่จะเร็วกว่านี้ค่ะ 5
นี้เป็นพี่โดเมตรต่อชั่วโมง
มันไม่ใช่ 80 ลิมิต 80
อ๋อถ้าเป็นเอ่อทางหลวงจากจังหวัดกรุงเทพ
ไปจังหวัดอื่นๆทางหลวงก็จะขับได้ที่ความ
เร็วไม่เกินไม่เกิน
แค่
110 กิโลเมตรต่อชั่วโมงโอเคอ๋อแต่อันนี้
120 วันนี้ไม่โอเค
นิดนึงนิดนึง
เดี๋ยวต้องโหลดมาดูคลิปนี้
นะคะ 100 ประมาณ 110 โอเคไม่ตำรวจตำรวจ
โอเค
ค่ะโอเคค่ะแล้วยังไงต่อคะอยากจะไปด้วย
แล้วค่ะอ้าวอันนี้ครับเราไปที่จังหวัด
กาญจนบุรีควรที่จะพาไปเดินเดินขึ้นภูเขา
กันโอ้ฉันอย่างนั้นหัวเข่าต้องดีใช่ไหม
ต้องแข็งแรงถ้วยต้องแข็งแรงอยากคุยกับเขา
นักเรียนหัวเข่าเขาต้องแข็งแรงขาต้องแข็ง
แรงด้วยกับเพราะว่าหน้าขาอยู่ตรงนี้อ่า
นี่หัวเข่าหัวเข่าตรงนี้ครับ
โอโห้กูอะตี้แข็งแรงนะว่าจะไปเดินหน้า
อยู่ที่ไหนอ่ะนี่นี่กลัวตีนไปเดินแบบนี้
เดินอยู่ตรงนี้เห็นไหมตัวเล่นค่ะเดี๋ยว
มันจะตกลงมาไม่คะห้องระวังนะครับเดี๋ยว
นักเรียนต้องระวังนะถ้าไปเดินกับครัวตี้
ไงสวัสดีคุ่คำถามก่อนที่จะไปนะค่ะตรงที่
กว้างกี่เมตรต้องตรงที่เดินกว้างประมาณ
ประมาณ 50 เซนติเมตร
ใช้ครับโอเคค่ะนักเรียนคู๋ถามแล้วกันนะคะ
ถ้า
ใครชอบตื่นเต้นนะคะมาประเทศไทยแล้วก็
โทรศัพท์ปากครู Arty เลยนะเดี๋ยวข้าไป
เดี๋ยวกลัวตี้พาไป
ใช่ครับคะไม้บรรทัดใน 30  cm นะคะให้ 2
ไม้บรรทัดต้องเอาไม้บรรทัดมาต่อกันโอ้ยกู
Arty  kuai ไปไม่ได้กูไอ้กลัวอ่ะ
ก็จะเดินได้ครับไม่น่ากลัวไม่น่ากลัวแต่
มันสูงอ่ะหนูได้กับสูงเดี๋ยวเวลาเดินเวลา
เดินก็จะมีกินลมมีลมล้มไหมคะมีลมพัดมา
อารมณ์
เย็นสบายครับไม่ล้มไม่ล้ม
ที่นี่ชื่ออะไรคะที่นี่ชื่อเขาช้างเผือก
เขาช้างเผือกจังหวัดการจังหวัดกาญจนบุรี
จังหวัดการหรือกาญจนบุรีๆ
แล้วเวลาขับรถไปเนี่ยต้องไปจอดตรงไหนอ่ะ
เราก็ต้องเป็นเงินกี่กิโลเมตรจอดอยู่ข้าง
ล่างครับแล้วก็เดินขึ้นไปขึ้นไปบนเขา
ประมาณประมาณ 4 กิโลเมตร
สี่กิโลเมตร
เดินขึ้นน่ะ 4 กิโลเมตรใช้ครับสีโลเมตรก็
จะไปถึงไปถึงต้องตรงจุดที่ตรงนี้ครับอ่ะ
มีการเป็นนามิก็หมายถึงเดินขึ้นเขาแล้วก็
เดินตรงตายครับอย่าเดิน 4 กิโลเมตรให้ทำ
เป็นได้หรอคะยังเต้นได้ครับมีที่กาง
เต้นท์อยู่อะเดี๋ยวกลัวที่มีรูปพี่ดูด้วย
เดี๋ยวเราจะเดินไปเดินไปด้วยกันแล้วก็ไป
กางเต้นด้วยกันอ่า
กลัวมีคนผักแล้วตก
ไม่มีเขาเอาที่นี่ที่นี่เขาอ่าไม่ให้เด็ก
ขึ้นไปคนที่จะไปที่นี่ต้องมีอายุอายุต้อง
มากกว่ามากกว่า 13 ปีขึ้นไปเพราะว่าเด็กๆ
ชอบวิ่งเล่นใช่ค่ะใช่ครับเด็กใหม่ไม่ได้
เล่นอาจจะตกได้
โอเคไปดูแล้วไปดูล่ะถ้าไปดูกันใช่ไหมครับ
อ่าเดี๋ยวกลัวตีเปิด
นี่ครับเปิดวีดีโอให้ดูตอนนี้เป็นวีดีโอ
ของครู Arty ดีๆใช่ครับมีเป็นวีดีโอของกู
อ่ะตี 5 เดี๋ยวมีครับกูอ่ะพี่ปิ๋ววิ่งเลย
ไปเที่ยวไปเที่ยวเข้าไปเที่ยวอ่ะอ่านี่
ครับพี่ชอบไปวิ่ง
มีไปวิ่งด้วยครับ
นี่รออยู่ที่เขาอยู่ที่ตลาดเข้าครับนับ
เป็นอุทยานแห่งชาติไทยทำเป็นอุทยานแห่ง
ชาติอุทยานแห่งชาติก็คือที่มีต้นไม้มากๆ
แล้วก็เป็นของประเทศไทยใช่ครับมีอุทยาน
แห่งชาติจังหวัดกาญจนบุรี
ต้นไม้ห้ามตัดต้นไม้ใช่ครับ
ก็มีพรุ่งนี้ไปไหนนะประตูเหรอคะใช่ครับ
เป็นทางเข้าทางที่จะเดินขึ้นไปบนภูเขานี้
ค่ะได้ครับและทุกคนก็เดินเดินตามทางไปนะ
ครับ
มีจะดูนะคะอ่ะ
ไม่มีปิดเป็นตรงๆแบบเป้ยมั๊ยอ่ะใช่ครับ
ทุกคนต้องสะพายสะพายเท่ของตัวเองไปเป้อาย
ใช่ครับกลัวนี่ก็มีเป้นี่กลัวนี่ก็สะพาย
เป้ไปนี่ตัวตี้เดินอยู่นี่อ๋อเหรอตายครับ
นะทางเดินเป็นแบบนี้ล่ะคะว่าตีครับตอนตอน
เริ่มต้นที่พึ่งเข้าไปก็จะเป็นป่าจะเป็น
ป่าสองข้างต้นอาจจะมีต้นไม้ขึ้นข้างๆต้น
สูงสูงกว่ากลัวตีนิดหน่อยนะครับแบบนี่ก็
ไข่เยอะเท่าไหร่อ่ะต้นไม้โอเคเป็นต้นไม้
เล็กๆมีครับทุกคนก็จะเดินไปตามทางไม่น่า
กลัวครับไม่น่ากลัว
เสียงตัวเอง
อายุ 25 นะ 25 นักเรียนคู่เอกก็อยากไปๆ
โอ้นี่ตอนนี้ก็คือ
กลัวใช่ไหมครับเห็นไหมครับไม่น่ากลัว
เพราะว่าเป็นป่า 2 ข้างค่ะ
มีครับแล้วก็มีท้องฟ้าวันนั้นแฝงฟ้าสวย
งามใช่ครับท้องฟ้าแฟนสีฟ้าสวยครับอากาศดี
อากาศดีอะตี้อันนี้กำลังเดินขึ้นข้างบน
หรือว่าเดินตรงๆกำลังเดินทางมันจะเป็น
เนินขึ้นลงพื้นลองไปเรื่อยๆแบบนี้ชายครับ
เนื้อหา
เกิดนึกว่าเดินขึ้นอย่างนี้ 4 กิโลเมตร
ถ้าขึ้นอย่างเดียว
ไปกับขึ้นไม่ไหว
ได้ทำหน้านี่วันนี้หน้าคนนี้เป็นลูกชาย
ลูกชายของครัวที่
โตแล้วนะโตแล้วโตแล้วลูกชายกลัวที่อายุ 18
แล้วครับไปได้
เป็น
ไปได้มาคุยกันได้ว่าขวดตีลูกเล็กๆ
อ่าโอเค
ไอ้นุ๊ก 1 คนหรือ 2 คนนะคะมีลูก 2 คนสำ
อาค์ไปคนเดียวหรอคะอีกคนหนึ่งเดินไปข้าง
หน้านะครับเดินไปไปๆแล้ว
อ่าเดินไปไกลๆแล้วพี่เอ๋ดูใกล้ๆดูลูกๆขวด
ตีตัวโตมากฮอดใช้กับรู้กลัวติดตัวสูง 0
เข้าขวดปีแล้วค่ะ
สวยอ่ะเดี๋ยวก็ตี้พามาดูตรงนี้ครับตรงนี้
อาจจะเป็นจุดที่อ่าๆเดี๋ยวนะชมวิวหรือ
เปล่าเป็นจุดที่ย่าเริ่มสูงขึ้นเรียกขึ้น
มาหน่อยน่ะเขาญาติเตี้ยว่าๆเลยนะ
เอาหน้านี้ครับเราจะเดินไปตรงโน้นเราต้อง
ไกลๆนู้นเลยเดินไปเล็กๆในม่วงชมพูนี่ใคร
คะเนี่ยอาคนนี้ใช่ไหมครับคนนี้ก็คือครูปี
ครับ
คนที่เอาค่าเอาค่ามาปิดไว้เพราะว่าแดดแดด
ร้อน 800 ปิดค่าไหวใช้น่า
จะเดินตรงไปอีกได้ครับนี่เดินตรงไปเรื่อย
ๆเลยสนุกไหมคะน่าสนุกครับสนุกครับอากาศดี
นะครับมองดูวิวดูวิวไกลไกลๆดูวิวไปๆๆ
นี่ครับลูกชายคนคนนะคะกู Arty ไป 4 คนชาย
ครับไปขวดตี้กับภรรยาของกลัวตี้แล้วก็ไป
กับลูกอีก 2 คนค่ะทั้งหมด 4 คนใช่ครับ
ทั้งหมดสิบบนแล้วมีคนอื่นๆไปด้วยไหมคะมี
คนอื่นไปด้วยครับอ๋ออ๋อที่อุทยานเขาขอให้
คนไปประมาณ 60 คนขอ 1 ครั้งได้ 60  1 วัน
1 วันมีคนขึ้นไปได้ประมาณ 60 คนอ๊อดนอน
ที่นั่นได้ 6 ทรายกับใช่ครับนอนได้ 6-10
คนคู๋รู้สึกสูงมากแต่ตอนนี้เพราะว่าเห็น
เห็นท้องฟ้าแล้วก็เห็นสีขาวๆหาทรายครับสี
เขาขาวนี้เป็นเมฆครับหน้านี่
มีเที่ยงครัวที่เดินมาแล้วเปอร์ตีเดินมา
จากจะเดินมาจากที่ไกลๆตรงโน้นตรงโน้นอัน
เดินเดินๆมาอ๋ออันนี้เป็นจุดพักแล้วหรอคะ
ได้ครับตอนนี้มีที่นั่งพักอยู่ที่นั่งอาจ
อยู่อันนี้ครึ่งนึงแล้วใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
ครึ่งหนึ่งแล้วครึ่งทางแล้วบอกพี่ครึ่ง
ทางแล้วก็คิดกลับหรือไปต่อฮ่าๆต้องไปต่อ
ครับไอ้ต่อกูเอกขอบครึ่งค่ะแล้วกลับถ้า
หากเราจะเดินไปไกลๆตรงโน้นที่กลางเต็นท์
ที่กางเต็นท์อยู่ตรงอยู่ตรงนี้ครับมีก็มี
ขายหน้าเดี๋ยวเราจะเดินไปกันเห้ยพูดได้
แล้วที่นั่นมีอาหารไหมอ่ะอ่าเราต้องเอา
อาหารขึ้นไปขึ้นไปทำกินเองควรที่เอามาม่า
ขึ้นไป
2 เบอร์นะเย็นกับเช้าๆอาตอนกลางวันด้วย
ตอนกลางวันที่เดินกว่าตีขึ้นไปตอนเช้า
ประมาณประมาณ 08:00 น 08:00 นเดินเดินๆ
แล้วก็ไปกินข้าวตอนเที่ยงที่ระหว่างฐาน
เอาหวาน / ที่จะไปถึงที่พักงั้นในใน
กระเป๋าก็ต้องมีอาหารมีอาหารมีน้ำในครับ
เอาล่ะมาม่าต้มยังไงอ่ะคะอ่าตอนเช้ากลัว
ที่ซื้ออาหารกล่อง
ใช่ครับขึ้นไปก็ไม่ต้องทำแกะกินเลยอ้าๆ
ครับ
ส่วนตอนเย็นตอนเย็นก็ไปต้มมาม่ากินที่
เต้นน่ะวันนี้อันนี้จุดครับนะครับผู้เอก
ที่อยากรู้พูดถามเร็ว
โอเค
อ่าเดี๋ยวเราจะเดินไปใกล้ๆกับเออโห้ให้
กว่าที่คิดว่าเรากำลังเหลือเวลาอีกนิด
หน่อยเดี๋ยวกลัวตีต้องรีบพาไป
ได้ได้เฟซเยอะขอโทษครับถามเยอะมากมองดู
เวลาโอเคอ่ะตอนนี้อ่าเราเดินมาถึงที่พัก
แล้วครับอ๋อโอเคค่ะหน้าเดี๋ยวคุณที่พัก
เดินไปดูที่พักก่อนนะครับเอาตรงนี้จะ
กว้างแล้วเนาะกว้างนี้มีพี่กว้างสามารถมี
พื้นที่ดินเห็นได้ใช่ครับ
5 นี้ครับนี้ผม
ขอทุกคนก็จะอยู่ที่เต็นท์นอนพักที่เต็ม
ก่อนนะครับ
เป็นไปด้วยใช่ไหมคะๆก๋วยเตี๋ยวเอาเต็นท์
ไปด้วยครับ
ปาร์ตี้แล้วท่านคุณอ่ะที่บอกลมแรงมีลมลม
แรงไหมใครบางคืนกลางคืนตอนครวญพี่นอนล้ม
แรงมากลมป่ะ too
ตัว
เอเลี่ยนละ
เหมาะสำหรับคนที่เล่นไหมเล่นน่ะ
ชอบตื่นเต้นไปได้ครับไม่ได้อันนี้เหมาะ
กับครูอตี้แล้วก็ลูกนะคะลูกอายุ 18
เลยเลยเวลา
แปลไปเอาน่าสนใจกู Arty กูอีกว่านักเรียน
น่าจะสนใจอันนี้สำหรับคนที่ชอบอะไรนะ
แบ็คแพ็คใช่ครับใกล้กับเราก็เดินเดินขึ้น
ไป
ฟรีหรือว่าต้องเสียเงินค่ะอ้าเสียเงิน
ครับเสียเงินเสียเงินไม่แพงนะครับประมาณ
กว่าตี้ประมาณอ่าประมาณเท่าไหร่ประมาณ 700
บาท 1 คน 700 หรือว่า 10  710 คนหนึ่งคน
หนึ่งคนจะว่าเพราะว่าจะมีเจ้าหน้าที่ไปไป
คอยดมีแต่เราด้วย
หน้าที่ของอุทยานไปด้วยเดินไปกับเราไปในๆ
ทรายครับก็จะเดินไปกับเรา
นี่ข้างบน
กว่าตี้อันนี้กูเอาตีนต้องโทรศัพท์จองไว้
ก่อนไหมคะถ้าจะไปใช่ครับต้องจองต้องจอง
ล่วงหน้าประมาณ 7 วัน
นี้ใช่ครับเพราะว่าเพราะว่าที่นี่รับได้
60 คนใช่ไหมคะใช่
ต้องต้องโทรศัพท์จองที่กรุงเทพหรือจองที่
กาญจนบุรีเลยค่ะ 5 โทรไปจองที่กาญจนบุรี
ได้เลยค่ะกลับอีกทีนะคะชื่ออะไรนะอ้าเขา
ช้างเผือกเขาช้างเผือกนะคะนักเรียนก็
เสิร์ชเอาใดอินเตอร์เน็ตนะคะเราอาจจะมี
เบอร์โทรศัพท์แล้วก็โทรศัพท์จองให้ใช่
ครับแล้วก็อ่าหนึ่งปีพอดีจะเปิดให้จอง
เอ่อรอบเดียวเปิดให้ขึ้นประมาณเดือน
เอ่อธันวาคมมกราคมกุมภาพันธ์ 3 เดือนพอ
เดือนเดือน 12 เดือนที่ 1 เดือนที่สองชาย
ใช้ค่ะ 2 แล้วกันหนึ่งแล้วก็ 2 ครับขอต่อ
หน้าหนาวหรอคะได้ครับตอนนั้นหนาวอ๋อหัว
หน้าร้อนหน้าร้อนไม่ให้ไป
หน้าร้อนไม่ไปเพราะว่าพอนอนการให้อุทยาน
ให้ป่าหามีความสมบูรณ์เป็นป่าป๋องอ่ะหนาว
เท่านั้นหน้าฝนได้นะคะหน้าฝนไม่ได้ครับ
เพราะว่าหน้าฝนเวลาฝนตกแล้วลื่นลื่นเวลา
เดินก็จะตกเขาลงไปเขาก็เลยไม่ให้ไปก็ได้
เฉพาะหน้าหนาวๆครับได้ช่าง
แล้วเดี๋ยวนิดหนึ่งไปและก็คือไปได้นอนได้
1 คืนชายครับนอนได้ 1 คืนแล้วก็กลับตื่น
มาก็เดินลงเดินปรับเนื้อใจครับน่าสนใจอ่า
หน้าไปครับน้าไปน้าไปค่ะไม่น่ากลัวไม่น่า
กลัวครับสนุกๆกว่าตีหน้าตาสนุกว่า
นักเรียนนักเรียนคิดว่าสนุกหรือน่า
สนุกนะนี่เดี๋ยวผมพามาถึงตรงที่ตรงที่
สูงที่สุดมีครับอยู่ข้างบนนี่มาถึงแล้ว
เขาสวยๆๆครับดูคนก็นอนอยู่ที่นี่นอนพัก
อยู่บนนี้ค่ะ
จากหน้าไปแล้วขอ Arty อ่านี่ครับอยู่บน
เขานี้เลยมองไปรอบๆเห็นทั้งหมดมีภูเขาหมด
เลย
เห็นเป็นวงกลมก็ได้ครับ
สวยโอเคนะกูขาวรอบตัวเลยตามร้อยหกสิบองศา
ค่ะหน้า
ควรตี้อุ้ยอุ้ยเหมือนถูกเขาแล้วมีทะเลรอบ
เลย
ใจเขาเป็นป่าเป็นก้อนแม่อ่า
ขวดดิคุยมีคำถามถ้าสมมติว่าไม่นอนที่นั่น
เดินไปตอนเช้าแล้วเดินกลับเลยได้ไหมคะถ้า
เดินไปตอนเช้าแล้วเดินกลับเลยได้ครับแต่
ก็จะเหนื่อยฉันเหนื่อยใช่ครับส่วนใหญ่คน
ที่ขึ้นไปก็จะนอนนอนพักคืนนึงหน้าแล้วก็
พุ่งชัดตอนเช้าก็เดินกลับถ้ากับ
หน้าไม่มีงูใช่ไหมคะกวนตีนไม่เจองูครับ
กูเอกกลัวงูเหรอเขาแดงนิดนึงพออ๋อเหรอ
ไหวใช่ไหมครับกาญจนบุรีจะอยู่อยู่ติดกับ
ประเทศพม่า
ติดกับมาบางทีก็พูดเนียนมากนะคะเลยครับก็
มีภูเขาอยู่
หน้าตรงนี้ที่เรายืนอยู่ไหนเราก็จะมอง
เห็นประเทศพม่าด้วยอย่าไปกลัวที่จำไม่ได้
แล้วอ่ะอยู่ด้านไหนไม่เป็นไรไม่รู้ว่าตรง
ไหนประเทศไทยตรงไหนพม่าแล้วนะเพราะว่า
เอ่อ
ภูเขาอันนี้ภูเขาที่เนี่ยเห็นลืมขึ้นและ
ภูเขาเนี่ยอยู่อยู่อยู่ที่ทองผาภูมิ
อำเภอ
กาญจนบุรีน่ะมีอำเภออำเภออำเภออำเภอมี
อำเภอทองผาภูมิ
อ.ทองผาภูมิก็จะติดกับเมียนมาร์ตายใจขับ
ก็ติดกับเมียนมางั้นแม่พอขึ้นไปบนภูเขาก็
เหมาะจะเห็นภูเขาของเมียนมาได้
โอ๊ยแต่ว่าตอนนี้เวลาหมดใช่ไหมคะครูอาจดิ
ครับเวลาหมดแล้วเดี๋ยวเรากลับเลยค่ะไปกู
เห็นแล้วก็อยากไปนักเรียนเออไปอยากไปแต่
ก็กลัวต
[เพลง]
ไม่นัดกลัวไม่น่าตัวสนุกเวลาไปถึงจริงๆ
เห็นภูเขาจริงๆของฟ้าจริงๆสวยสุขสนุกๆก็
ต้องถ่ายรูปตรงนี้ใช่ไหมหาใช่กับนี้อยู่
บนยอดหาโอเคค่ะโอเคค่ะอ้าเดี๋ยวคราวหน้า
คราวหน้ากลับมาเจอกับครูปาร์ตี้กับครูพี่
เอกกันใหม่นะครับเราจะพาไปเที่ยวจังหวัด
ไหนอ่าต้องปิดนี้เป็นแบบเที่ยวสไตล์ผู้
ชายฮ่าๆๆ
หนึ่งเป็นผจญภัยตื่น this  App  Please  I
ก็เที่ยวแบบผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวคลิปต่อไปให้ครู
เอ๋เป็นคนคาไปเที่ยวบ้างได้ค่ะโอเคค่ะ
คลิปนี้ไปก่อนนะคะสวัสดีครับสวยครับพี่
เอ๋ดีค่ะเรียนบ๊ายบายน